trailer Matt wall show Disney serves up
some more historically illiterate white
Guild teaching children that quote
slaves built this country and that's why
we should start Doling out reparations
this is all completely wrong on many
levels and I'll explain why also a
terrifying mob of morbidly obese
insurrectionists invade the Oklahoma
state capitol to demand the right to
mutilate and castrate children and
Tennessee moves forward with its Bill to
Outlaw sexual performances for children
a measure that Democrats in the state
call anti-lgbt but what does that tell
us finally in our daily cancellation I'm
forced to cancel a right-wing
commentator who has found yet another
totally erroneous reason to accuse me of
racism all of that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep I'm guessing that's why
you need to check out Helix mattress
I've had my Helix for years now and I
absolutely love it I sleep like a baby
and that's uh when I'm actually able to
sleep because I have newborn twins but
when that happens I do sleep well a
mattress should never be a
one-size-fits-all solution because why
should you have to compromise on Comfort
Helix has a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else go
to helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz and find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type your mattress will come right to
your door for free plus Helix has a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will so for limit time
Helix is giving you 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners take advantage of this amazing
offer at helixsleep.com Walsh with Helix
better sleep starts now
one of the most uncontroversial pieces
of marriage advice I can give is that
it's never a good idea to focus
obsessively on the sins of the past even
though you know this is a common mistake
that people make in romantic
relationships most people understand
intellectually at least that it's not
productive or healthy to dwell on the
slights that your spouse has committed
in the past or the hurts they caused you
long ago in an argument as soon as you
utter the phrase oh yeah well remember
the time when you fill in the blank
you've likely destroyed any chance of
reaching any Mutual understanding or
worthwhile resolution once you bring
ancient history into discussion you've
stopped having a discussion and instead
turned it into a game of scoring points
everything is clouded Now by resentment
and grudges nothing is solved by your
decision to root through the past in
search of ammo to use against your
spouse in the present day you've only
created more problems
without doing anything to address
whatever problem started the argument in
the first place often you've taken some
small disputes and turned it into a much
bigger deal than it ever needed to be so
one minute
you're squabbling because your wife gave
you a hard time about not using a
coaster when you put your drink down on
the coffee table the next minute you're
rehashing an argument dating back to
2009. this is why it's best to move on
from what has already happened and
already been hashed out and allow your
marriage to exist in the present moment
where you both have control over the
outcome
you cannot change the past you only have
power over the present and therefore to
some extent the future
now if this principle applies to
marriages so too does it apply to much
larger groups like say a nation in fact
it applies even more to Nations than to
marriages because at least the
infractions committed by your spouse in
the past were actually committed by your
spouse whereas the resentment that one
group in a country may carry against
another group in the country will often
stem from sins that were not committed
by anyone living today nor against
anyone living today
I mean it's one thing to hold someone's
past sins against them even that is
often counterproductive and unjust but
it's an entirely uh different thing a
much worse thing to hold someone's past
sins against someone else who had
nothing to do with them
yet this is exactly the situation that
the woke race Hustlers have tried
desperately and with horrifying success
to engineer
one of the reasons they've been so
successful in stirring up these
resentments keeping ancient wounds fresh
and still bleeding is that they start
the resentment building process very
early making sure to preach the
grievance gospel the children from a
very young age
case in point the latest Uber woke
episode from Disney's Uber woke children
show which is called the proud family
now for a little bit of background the
proud family was originally a kids show
on the Disney Channel back in the early
2000s it was canceled in 2005 and then
in 2022 it became uh just the latest
reboot that nobody needed nobody asked
for nobody wanted the rebooted proud
family which can be found now on Disney
plus promises to be louder and prouder
and it certainly fulfills at least half
of that promise a clip from a recent
episode has gone viral over the past few
days and in it we are treated to what
we're told is a rap or a song about the
Sinister origins of the United States
and here it is
this country was built on slavery which
means slaves built this country till
this land from sea to Sea to Sea first
there was rice tobacco sugarcane
and we weren't soldiers four million
strong fighting for America's freedoms
even though we remained America slave
between the descendants of slaves
continue to build this slaves built this
country and we the descendants of slaves
in America have earned reparations for
their suffering and continue to earn
reparations every moment we spend
submerged in systemic Prejudice racism
and white supremacy that America was
standing with and still has not a tone
for slaves built this country not only
filled hands but Carpenters Masons
blacksmiths musicians
Washington Washington 40 acres and a
mule we'll take the 40 acres keep the
mill we made your families rent from the
southern plantation air to the northern
Banker to the New England ship owner the
founding fathers for my brother my
present current Senator the Illuminati
the New World Order of slaves built this
country we had Tubman Turner Frederick B
didn't they say Lincoln free the slave
but slaves were men and women and only
we can free ourselves emancipation is
not Freedom Jim Crow segregation
redlining Public Schools feeding private
prisons where we become slaves again as
we celebrate June 10th time our account
is still outstanding cause this country
was built on slavery which means slaves
built this country and we demand our 40
acres and a mule
keep the 40.
freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
just some nice wholesome children's
content so I'll stick with the bluey I
think
okay first of all
uh there's been some misinformation
about the content of that clip people
are saying that the Disney show featured
a you know an anti-American song
well that is anti-American but it's not
a song it's literally just shrill voices
chanting vacuous bumper sticker slogans
without rhyme or rhythm
which I guess you know sap doesn't
really separate it much from uh many
other pop songs but as Martin Luther
King would say we should judge woke
propaganda by not by its shrillness but
by its content the content here is
ridiculous on multiple levels levels so
let's let's go through them first and
most importantly
um and it is really necessary that we
emphasize that slaves did not build this
country
um this country was built over the
course of hundreds of years beginning
long before it was a country the
building started in the 1400s when the
first European explorers sailed across
treacherous and Uncharted Seas to
discover these lands it continued with
the European settlers in the 1500s and
1600s who built a life for themselves in
this unknown Wilderness facing Untold
threats and for many of them certain
death
this country was built by the colonists
and the American revolutionaries was
built by the Pioneers who expanded the
country from the East heading west out
into a hostile Wilderness occupied by
warring Indian tribes it was built by
War and conquest by Discovery by
diplomacy by industry
it was built and then nearly undone by a
civil war that killed 620 000 men then
built up again only to thrive once more
the country was built by the people who
made it into the world's great power in
the 20th century who won World Wars and
brought about peace and economic
Prosperity it was built by many people
over many centuries
and for a portion of that history some
people in some parts of the country own
slaves
that certainly is not enough to justify
the claim that the slaves built the
country
to make that claim is to erase nearly
everyone who really did build the
country it's to paper over America's
actual history with your
grievance-mongering nonsense
now if the mere historical fact of
slavery automatically means that the
country was built by slavery and forever
is indebted to slaves and their
descendants then of course the same must
be said about every nation on the planet
there is no race no people uh no Nation
anywhere in the world who does not
inherit the guilt of of slavery
if indeed the guilt of slavery can be
inherited
as I will never Tire of pointing out the
only thing that makes America's
relationship to slavery unique
is how comparatively quickly we
abolished it
and the lengths we went to abolish it
Western nations were patrolling the
oceans patrolling the oceans to shut
down the slave trade for for many years
while non-western Nations did everything
in the power to continue the slave trade
also
you notice something you notice how I
didn't use the word we
when talking about the people who did
build the country
okay a great many of the pioneers and
explorers and inventors and Warriors and
Statesmen and leaders Etc who built the
country were white
I mean most of them were white that's
that's that's the historical reality it
just is
and we certainly shouldn't be ashamed of
pointing that out or let ourselves be
shamed into not pointing it out or
denying it
yet as a white person I don't say we
because we would include me and I didn't
do any of those things I didn't come
here on the Mayflower I wasn't on the
Lewis and Clark expedition I didn't
fight in the Civil War I didn't storm
the beaches of Normandy
people who looked kind of like me did
but I didn't
so I don't take credit for their
achievements or claim their accolades
just as I don't pretend to have
experienced their suffering or felt
their pain
I stand at the end of this long line of
Triumph and sacrifice I am its
beneficiary
and so are you whatever your race
yet in that Disney song
that's not really a song
we hear the word we being used and this
is always the case with the race
hustlers they talk about the long ago
sufferings of people they never met and
who they missed meeting by a century and
a half and they say we and us
but no it's not a we are enough
situation because you were not enslaved
that didn't happen to you it just didn't
it may have happened to your ancestors
but if you go back a little further you
may just as well find that your
ancestors did it to others see you this
is this is the problem of trying to
claim uh you know your entire lineage as
if it all happened to you is that you
cannot isolate this one particular
moment in your ancestry and take direct
ownership of it
speaking about it as if you were there
without owning all of the rest of your
ancestral history a history that is
guaranteed to include brutality and
impression inflicted on others by your
ancestors because literally everyone's
ancestors are guilty of that
because that is the story of the human
race
not the white race the human race
so
alternatively
you can choose to stand in the present
on your own two feet
appropriating neither your ancestors
achievements nor their sufferings
nor their sins
you could be your own person
located in this moment of time
equipped with the freedom and luxury
given to you by those who died long
before you were born
it's your choice really you've got two
paths
and one gives you a chance at Living a
happy and successful life
the other keeps you wallowing
pathetically in self-pity obsessing over
resentments that don't belong to you
it's up to you
now let's get to our headlines
if the past couple of years have taught
us anything at all it's that in a crisis
like a global pandemic or a natural
disaster even the basics can be really
hard to come by you need to be prepared
for anything that's why my new partners
at Jace medical are so important and
they are here to help Chase Medical's
position is to empower you to be more
prepared better medically prepared
especially even in the worst case
scenario is a great way to start is with
the Jace case a pack of five different
courses of antibiotics that you can use
to treat a whole host of bacterial
illnesses including UTIs respiratory
infections sinuses uh skin infections
and many more all you have to do is fill
out a simple online form in some cases
jump on a quick call with one of their
board certified Physicians from there
you can ask your physician treatment
related questions on an ongoing basis
look with six kids it's always good to
be prepared for anything because like I
never know what will happen having the
Jace case on hand makes it easy for my
family to be prepared for what life life
throws our way what you got to do is go
to jacemedical.com enter code wall
should check out for a discount on your
order that's jasonmedical.com promo code
Walsh
okay so the post-millennial reports
trans activists gathered in the
Oklahoma's capital on Monday to protest
legislation that would prohibit the
sterilization and mutilation of children
trans lives matter they chanted the
legislative session began in the state
on Monday and lawmakers are expected to
consider the millstone act which would
prohibit Oklahoma doctors from providing
gender transition procedures or Referral
Services relating to such procedures to
anyone under the age of 26.
quality bill would further authorize the
state's attorney general to enforce the
act and those found guilty of violating
it would be guilty of a felony and
subject to license revocation says
released from State Senator David
Bullard
child abuse is a felony in our state and
mutilating in young children person's
genitalia should be viewed no
differently the millstone act will hold
those who perform child mutilation
accountable by making such activity a
felony those guilty of such a heinous
crime will be both legally and
financially liable according to Bullard
and 25 is a
a later cut off than most bills in other
states that are doing something similar
but I think 25 makes a lot of sense for
reasons that we've talked about that
you're you know your your brain is not
fully developed your prefrontal cortex
isn't really fully online so speak uh
until the age of 25 which means that you
don't you don't fully have your your
capacities of discernment long-term
decision making all those things are not
um haven't been fully developed yet
and so it makes sense
that we wouldn't allow people to
um cosmetically mutilate their bodies to
this extreme extent
before their brains have been fully
developed
so I think it's a great bill and I also
like that now I I don't I it's not in
here so I'm not sure exactly why they
call it the millstone Act
but if that is a reference to the
millstone that supposed that Jesus says
you know we we would you know if you're
if you're rather than harming a child
you'd be better with a millstone around
your neck drowning and thrown into the
sea like if it's a reference to that
Millstone then that's amazing that's
awesome
it's my favorite name for a bill
probably ever
during a state of State address Governor
Kevin Stitt said send me a bill that
bans all gender transition surgeries and
hormone therapies on minors in the state
of Oklahoma previously signed bills that
ban biological males from competing in
women's sports and require sex
segregated bathrooms and schools to
remain segregated regardless of a
student's state
and gender identity
so this is the bill that they're
considering they're gearing up to pass
and the trans activists in the state and
apparently there are some trans
activists in Oklahoma uh relatively
sizable amounts of them and as you'll
see when I say sizable you know I mean
that in a couple different ways but they
stormed the capital
last night okay they weren't just
outside they went into the building
and we have a couple of clips of that
let's pull these up
[Applause]
they're they're in the building this is
an insurrection
[Applause]
February 6th is when this happened the
day that will live in infamy
we will all remember February 6th
from here forward every February 6th we
should solemnly recall where we were
when we heard about this insurrection
okay
this is worse than 9 11.
this is Pearl Harbor and 911 combined
we'd like to see
okay can you uh pause it there pause it
quick here we go just keep that up
keep that uh
gang behind me as I as I
discuss a few points here okay so first
of all everybody you see in this clip
they should all be arrested and thrown
in federal prison because that's what we
do with uh insurrections right that's
that's what we're told people that
invade the capital
angry mobs
we throw them in prison and we do it
without without uh without trial
they don't get any lawyers throw them in
solitary confinement
that's what we should do because that's
what that's what we're told that's
supposed to be the reaction to this sort
of thing
only if you're going to arrest them you
know you need a lot of buses to handle
all these people uh because there's a
lot of them
there are a lot of them as a group and
as individuals there's also a lot of
them
because it is very interesting to me
that these you know I mean the the
average BMI I think in this group is
probably hovering in the 40 to 50 range
but as you can see especially if you
with with the other shot where it shows
the whole crowd
um in spite of that fact they are all
being very healthy or many of them are
being healthy to make sure they have
masks on
so morbidly obese but they're they're
wearing their masks anyway for the
insurrection
and that is actually you know I pointed
this out on Twitter that that you know
this this group here is I mean they're
they're it's just it's noticeable
that like everyone in the crowd is
overweight
that's a that's a noticeable fact and I
pointed that out and some people were
offended and said well that's beneath
you Matt that's beneath you
how dare you make that observation
that's juvenile
well a couple things about that
first of all
even if I was simply just insulting them
and degrading them just for the sake of
it if that was my point to to insult
these people
well they would deserve it I mean there
is nothing that I could say about these
people that would be over the line
because what are they doing
they are storming the capital to
demand the right to mutilate and
castrate and sterilize children these
people are evil to their core and that's
what I I I feel as though
there are many people out there still
don't fully understand this even even
the conservatives who understand that we
shouldn't be capturing children
I think that there's still this desire
to see these people as uh well well
they're wrong but they're well
intentioned they're just confused and
they have a different point of view and
and that's all
this is not a different point of view
sort of situation
there are plenty of issues where we can
disagree and you can have and you know
there a a well-intentioned and good
person could fall on either side of it
that's the case for many of the issues
including the kind of issues that we
argue about all the time in the country
you could be a well-intentioned it
basically do some person and fall on
either side of the issue
because well-intentioned these people
can be wrong about stuff
but I'm sorry
uh you cannot be well-intentioned and
decent
while
defending the castration mutilation and
Butchery of children that doesn't exist
the physical and sexual abuse of
children because that's what all this is
and that's what they're and so these are
terrible awful people
and we should mock them and deride them
and Heap total utter contempt on them
and the message should be very clear
that the position they are holding is
not acceptable it is not an acceptable
position in civilized society
you can hold the position we can't stop
you you're allowed to think and believe
whatever you want
but it's not acceptable it's not
tolerable we're not going to tolerate it
it's not valid there's no validity to it
and if you hold that position and you
say it out loud you have revealed
something about your you know the core
of Who You Are
you have revealed that at your core you
are an absolute monster
and that's how you should be treated
that's what the left us does
okay and it's a very effective tactic
actually
like no matter what they say they treat
us they no matter what we say they treat
us as monsters no matter what we say
but for them it's it's performance it's
over compensation
because they don't really have an
argument so instead they they fall back
on that
the difference here is that this
actually is monstrous and so we should
say that and be clear about it I have no
respect for any of these people
and yes they are fat hideous ugly people
inside and out
the other thing too is that uh you do
notice this about left-wing activists I
mean they they are just ugly I mean they
are hideous people they really are
that's a phenomenon
that I think is is worth talking about
this it's a it's a it's an interesting
phenomenon at the very least
what I think is the ugliness in their
souls seeps out of them and warps their
physical exterior
and these are also self-loathing people
you know they hate the world they hate
themselves they hate Humanity they hate
children they hate everything
and so they don't take care of
themselves as you can clearly see here
um and if it were up to me I really
would arrest them all because fair is
fair
this is what they say I guarantee every
single person this picture every single
one
in that crowd
thinks that you know the uh the January
6 quote insurrectionists ought to have
been arrested as they were rounded up
and thrown in prison every single one of
them believes that and so the same
thing should happen to them and it was
up to me that's exactly what I would do
hold them to their own standards
you can't live by your own standards
then you then that should tell you
something
all right
moving over to Tennessee
well we've got the the bill here in
Tennessee which also is going to
um is going to ban the castration
mutilation of children
there's also there's another bill that's
making its way through uh the the
through the process right now to become
law and that is a bill to criminalize
well it's it's what we're being told is
that it criminalizes drag shows or drag
shows for children which it does
but that's not
what the bill is solely focused on what
the bill actually does is it
criminalizes sexual performances for
children of any variety
okay so you can't hold any kind of
sexual performance and involve children
in it
um now on on the left and the Democrats
in Tennessee they have taken that to be
an attack on drag in particular which
like what does that tell you
when you say you know what we should ban
sexual performances for children and
they immediately respond by saying what
so you think the drag should be banned
oh oh so you're admitting that this is a
sexual performance for children huh
anyway WKRN uh here locally has a report
on that let's watch that
three today
so known as the bell to potentially
criminalize drag shows the bill went
before two different committees
including the criminal justice
subcommittee news 2's Chris O'Brien
brings us inside
the eyes developed the bill moves on if
you wish to be recorded as a no please
see the clerk in front of a packed house
the house criminal justice subcommittee
voted to advance a bill to potentially
criminalize certain drag shows and we
are fighting against a group of folks
who were set on hate but really have no
understanding of what this looks like in
in theory in practice multiple people
testified against the bill saying it
unfairly reprimands the lgbtq community
last week I went to her drag show and I
was forced to walk past a mob of masked
men with guns and swastikas to get into
that drag show but the sponsor of
Madison County Republic that didn't
happen so that's a lie that didn't
happen a group with swastikas and guns
do we have a video of that any pictures
of that
whole group of Nazis with with swats
that goes outside the drag show
I mean if they're if there were any
swastikas which I highly doubt that
actually happened
um it's almost certainly that that's
going to be the left that has them but
you know that's almost certainly leftist
agitators who are you know walking
around with swats that goes so they
could try to blame it on the right they
they do do that that's something that
they do on occasion but most likely that
was just made up anyway continue
applicant representative Chris Todd says
his bill has nothing to do with track
shows and why are we targeting this one
thing
thank you Mr chairman and so far Mr
chairman the only person that's
mentioned anything about drag has been
the representative from Knox County I
haven't said a word about that
Republicans did have some concerns
particularly on the vagueness of the
bill Tendencies on Miley Cyrus at
Bridgestone Arena
I've seen her there in the past myself
would that cross the line
could she be subject to a pair of
handcuffs based upon well I hope so
vagueness ultimately that answer would
depend on if this bill passes the full
legislature for now the bill rests with
the full criminal justice Committee in
Nashville Chris O'Brien
criminal justice
probably shouldn't bring kids so Miley
Cyrus show uh at least that might maybe
it's a Miley Cyrus show 15 years ago or
something it'd be one thing but in the
modern yeah who would bring
what Miley Cyrus current day Miley Cyrus
you're gonna bring uh what you're
bringing a seven year old to that
if that's the if that's the the slippery
slope here
where now all of a sudden you can't even
bring kids to a Miley Cyrus show okay
good
what how is that some sort of like
horrifying dystopian reality
now I think it's actually really easy
though to distinguish between something
like a drag show
um and uh you know a pop star musical
performance it would be pretty easy to
distinguish between those things
and I think even in the language of the
spill it succeeds in doing that but my
point is that if you were to accept the
slippery slope argument I don't see it
as a problem
to have some basic standards of decency
um
especially as it pertains to content
that that where children are involved
that's that's yes we should have that
historically in this country we've
always had that it's only very recently
where we've decided that that well the
government has no role whatsoever in
enforcing any standards of decency at
all
even when it comes to kids
and so if the sexual degenerates and
perverts want to expose themselves to
kids all day long and have sexual
performance of kids there's nothing we
can do because if we were to do anything
at all next thing you know we're in a
handmaid's tale like it's only it's only
very recently that people in this
country have become stupid enough to buy
an argument like that
now the the reporter there in the in the
news article is not being honest
uh what we hear is that uh is that the
sponsors of this bill claim that it has
nothing to do with drag shows and
they're not saying it has nothing to do
with drag shows they're saying it's not
specifically outlawing drag shows what
they're saying is it Outlaws sexual
performances for children
and if there's a drag show that falls
under that umbrella then yes it would be
banned
but this would also ban for example
um a burlesque performance with with uh
featuring women where children are
involved we banned that too
now you might point out that that's not
really happening that most of this stuff
is involving drag
but that only tells you something about
the people that are putting on these
shows only that that just tells you
something about drag I mean if if
the whole drag industry will come
crashing down if they aren't allowed to
involve children anymore well then it
sounds like the drag industry is is one
that should come Crashing Down
foreign
so much because they don't even a bill
like this that prohibits sexualized
performances for children
they don't the left they don't just
claim that it's anti-drag they say that
it's anti-lgbt
so if you want a bill that says
um you can't put on a sexual performance
for kids
you can't like
strip and tear clothes off in front of
kids
you can't have you can't bring your
sexual fetishes out and put on a
performance featuring them if you say
that then they say Well that's anti-lgbt
yeah
what are you saying about the LGBT
community
that
if we tell you that you can't sexualize
kids that is somehow are are you saying
that this is uh that that sexualizing
children is a is a central fundamental
aspect of LGBT culture is that what
you're saying
because that would seem to be what you
are saying
if you are claiming that a bill Banning
the sexualization of children is
anti-lgbt
all right something else here
uh kind of an update to story from
yesterday we talked about of course the
Satanic ritual at the Grammys and
conservatives reacting to it the way any
normal sane person reacts to a
nationally publicized Satanic ritual
um which is that from from certainly
this is the case for me but from any
other conservative that I've seen on
social media or elsewhere or or in the
media um
most conservatives said well this is
disgusting and grows many have pointed
out as I did that although it's
disgusting gross it's also tedious and
boring with derivative we've seen this a
million times so that's kind of been the
reaction
um I haven't seen anyone like running
through the street like their hair's on
fire screaming and crying about it
exactly
but people have objected as they should
and yet the left has launched into and
and the left-wing medium particular is
launched into their usual routine of of
making the story about our reasonable
reaction rather than about the thing
that we are reasonably reacting to
so just one brief example of this of
many is from the website the AV club
and uh it the headlines Sam Smith wore
devil horns of the Grammys and
conservatives are losing it
the article continues as similarly seen
with Lil Nas X's devilish Montero um in
2021 conservatives had their satanic
Panic panties and a Twist over last
night's performance from Sam Smith and
Kim Petrus the two took the Grammy stage
for performance of their song Unholy
which won the award for best pop duo in
addition to Petros making history as the
first out-transgender woman to win the
category she and Smith stoked the Flames
of controversy with a fiery hell-themed
performance much to conservative Chagrin
bone-headed political Abomination Ted
Cruz added his two cents last night
calling the set evil Marjorie Taylor
green also tweeted about the performance
fit with a Pfizer conspiracy two
dimwitted to even bother breaking down
aside from the blatant thematic ties to
Unholy Petrus says that the Red Lace
performance was inspired by the Duo's
experience with religious institutions
Petra's told variety I think a lot of
people honestly have kind of labeled
what I stand for and what Sam stands for
as religiously not cool and I personally
grew up wondering about religion and
wanted to be a part of it but slowly
realizing it didn't want me to be a part
of it so it's a take on not being able
to choose religion and not being able to
live the way that people might want you
to live because as a trans person I've
already not kind of wanted in religion
so we were doing a take on that and I
was kind of Hell keeper Kim like the
discussion around Lil Nas X and his
striptease with the devil conservatives
love to ignore storytelling contests
context opting to spout off nonsense
about queer and trans artists peddling
out Satanism and immoral Lifestyles to
oh my the children
okay Etc et cetera yes those
conservatives who absurdly you know with
their conspiracy theories that these
people are peddling satanism
as they literally dress as Satan and put
on a performance that they admit was
meant to resemble and therefore is a
Satanic ritual
so they admit that's what they're doing
and then we notice it and say look
they're doing a Satanic ritual
and then the media comes along and says
you know conspiracy theorists claiming
that it's a Satanic ritual
I get so tired of this of this routine
this routine of intentionally trying to
provoke people
and then when they're provoked blaming
them for being provoked
and this is all it's all meant to
desensitize
um and it's meant to convince
conservatives that anytime something
like this happens uh what we should
really do is say nothing at all and
remain quiet and compliant and just be
uh good little boys and girls and and
and you know say nothing while the
satanists carry on
with their BDSM themed uh satanic
performances that's that's what it's
supposed to be
that's what that's how they want us to
react and there are some conservatives
that that that is how they react and
that's what they claim even after this
there were some conservatives on social
media who were saying well don't don't
give them what they want and talk about
this just move on
um no actually that's not what they want
like what what they really want yeah I
mean if we talk about it then they're
gonna try to use that to their advantage
because that's how the game is played
right
um
and they're going to try to use that to
make victims of themselves and generate
more publicity and all the rest of it
but what they really want most of all
is to be in a culture where they can
carry on this way and uh nobody will
object whatsoever that's that's what
they're ultimately
fighting for
is a culture that is that is totally
succumbs to this stuff
and so if you remain silent and do not
object then then you you are you are
helping them towards that end
which to me seems rather obvious finally
as we've discussed on this show you know
yesterday we talked about marriage and
you know husbands and wives and what
makes men happy Etc
um I think partly you know it's as a
consequence of this conversation there's
this Tick Tock video that has gone viral
showing uh once again another one of
these day in the life tick tocks and
this one shows a a stay-at-home husband
we've seen one of these recently but
this one somehow manages to be even
worse and uh here it is
day one of being a stay-at-home husband
made us some tea and cuddled on the
couch
and then I started to pack her lunch
before she went to work with all her
favorite foods
snuck in a love note drove her to work
came back to a mess proof of me cleaning
the mess
juice break
put away some leftovers from the night
before starting to unpack met my wife at
the train stop had dinner together
packed her lunch
can't forget her snacks
I sent her off to bed
so I'm based on what I've been uh told
like this is what women actually want
right this is this is this is what women
are looking for the stay-at-home husband
who will uh
make them snacks and cuddle with them
and you know wait waiting there like a
puppy dog when they get home from work
so they can provide you know that's what
we want right to provide for a man who's
sitting around at home waiting for her
to get back
that's what that's what it's it's
insisted that that's what women want and
in fact it's insisted that women should
want that and that conversely men should
should also want to live the life that
we see there
um and yet it's just uh it's just not
the reality in practice
and we know that for a lot of reasons
one of them by the way is that um
if you're if if this is the life that
you choose your chances of getting
divorced are much higher
in fact when when they when uh even if
both man and husband and wife are
working
as soon as the wife earns more than the
husband divorce rates go up by 50
percent
okay that's not my opinion that's just
what happens
and that again is in most cases where
the husband was working
now if the if the wife is earning the
most because the husband's not working
anything earning anything because he's
at home
then it's likely the diverse divorce
rates are even higher than that
so they're trying to shape our desires
and tell us what we should want and yet
reality always has this way of uh just
intruding uh inconveniently into that
picture now let's get to our comment
section
[Music]
we all know when you're trying to find
the right person there are specific
things to look for such as uh someone
who shares the same goals beliefs and
values or if they're part of the sweet
baby gangs which tells you that all the
other things line up too bad there's not
some sort of technology that can easily
find the right person for you but if
you're hiring there is technology that
you can quickly that you can use that
will quickly help you find the right
person and that is zip recruiter head to
ziprecruiter.com Walsh and try it for
free today ZipRecruiter uses powerful
technology to find the right candidates
for your job if you see a candidate you
like you can easily send them a personal
invite so they're more likely to apply
their user-friendly dashboard makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates all from one place let zip
recruiter help you find the best people
for all of the roles in your company
four out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day you could see for
yourself how easy it is go to
ziprecruiter.com Walsh to try
ZipRecruiter for free again that's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire
actually here's even some more proof
that uh of the difference in the Sexes
and every day I'm confronted with the
the shocking reality that men and women
are different boys and girls are
different
um so just yet another example my
nine-year-old daughter was going to a
sleepover on Saturday night and we don't
do a lot of sleepovers but it's a it's a
good
you know it's a good family and they
don't they don't do phones or any of
that with their kids or some other kids
have phones we have to worry about that
just all around we we trust them so
anyway my daughter is
heading out to our sleepover and she's
got this uh duffel bag
packed with stuff I mean the duffel bag
weighs probably 55 pounds it would be
it's like if you tried to check it at
the airport you'd get charged an
overweight bag fee for it
um and uh it's stuffed to the brim with
with supplies this is what she's
bringing for one night
the Sleep sleepover party started at
like four o'clock and she was back home
by eight in the morning that's a what a
maybe a 16 hour stretch you need
apparently 25 out outfits and other
supplies as well doesn't include her
pillow and sleeping bag now meanwhile
it's a difference in this axis if we are
uh going away on vacation
for let's say a week or even longer and
we tell our twin brother to go and and
pack
which the last couple of times we've
tried this we it's like we have the kids
pack for themselves
and they will say well go go pack for
the ship and her brother was like okay
and he'll run upstairs and he'll come
back down in three and a half minutes
with two T-shirts and a pair of
sweatpants thrown into a plastic grocery
bag and that and that's his plan for a
week or longer that's all he needs
so that's just one of the differences
and of course I don't think she actually
used most of the supplies or clothing
that she brought but uh she did come
home the next morning dead tired like a
walking zombie and complaining that her
friends were talking until like two in
the morning and kept her awake and then
they started singing songs from uh from
the greatest showman at like one or two
in the morning and she was complaining
about this and and I said what do you
expect there's a sleepover with a bunch
of girls it's it's like this is this is
I assume what happens
though I can't imagine how much talking
must have gone on if it even annoyed my
daughter of all people
all right
um
let's see boundary elephant says
interesting that Matt having a cold
doesn't make him sound like someone with
a cold it makes him sound like the AI
generated voice that Candace made
Wayne Donald says crazy that Matt Walsh
with a cold sounds like the AI version
of himself for all I know this entire
episode was a deep fake and uh
Etc like EV 90 of the comments we're
making fun of my voice because I I do
have a cold and I'm like slightly losing
my voice and uh
there was part of me that that hoped
that maybe most of the audience would
they'd just be mature about it I know my
voice sounds weird you don't have to
point it out and make me feel
self-conscious about it but then at the
same time I realized it wouldn't be the
sweet baby gang if you didn't all give
me a hard time and mock me ruthlessly
for how I sound it's it's what I would
do
I understand it's the right thing to do
and so it's all right
um
Steve the Grand Marshal says Matt I
agree with you on almost everything but
I disagree on the DiCaprio thing it's
honestly just creepy that a 50 year old
man is dating a girl old enough to be
his granddaughter even if she's legally
capable of consent it's still very weird
and honestly the power Dynamic there is
also concerning so
I don't think you disagree with me in
that case because I never said that uh
it's a good idea for a 50 year old man
to date a 19 year old
um woman
and ever since a good idea
what I said is that the the the
feminists that are drawing a comparison
to this and like child rape and child
molestation who are saying that he's a
sex predator okay that's absurd that's
my point and then my second point is to
observe the uh
the the many contradictions that are
present in this idea that a 19 year old
can't fully consent to dating Leonardo
DiCaprio but a 15 year old girl can
consent having her breast removed and
all the rest of it went through
yesterday so that was my point now
um
is so does that mean that it's uh that
as a 50 year old man you should go date
a 19 year old no I don't think so I I
would never want to do that's like the
idea I'm 36. I would have what would you
even say what would you say to a 19 year
old I don't think I'd even have anything
to talk about so I couldn't possibly
relate to them on any level because not
it's not just the age Gap I mean the age
Gap is quite significant
but um you know there's not all age gaps
are made the same so if you're 35 dating
someone who's significantly older than
you that's one thing if you're 19 dating
someone stick to the older and say it's
just you're you're because at 35 you're
and you're you've been an adult for a
long time you uh
you're in a different place in life so
it's really about what what the place
you are in life and so it's making it
really hard to relate now
on the other hand
um
I would imagine that Leonardo DiCaprio
is not dating these girls because he's
looking for interesting
conversationalists
so he's probably not as worried about
the fact that he doesn't have much to
say to them
because that's not what this is about
for him
um
and it did there's there's one other
contradiction here that I think and
other people have pointed this out
but when you compare the left's reaction
or that not everyone on the left but
this is like this is a it's this seems
to be a feminist thing that's starting
now where they they uh take these
Hollywood actors that date younger
adults and try to turn them into sex
Predators but
consider for a second this point
if Leonardo DiCaprio
was
paying this woman directly
and in a sense he is because she's with
him for the status and the money and the
gifts and all the trips and everything
and uh and
he's with her because she's a good
looking uh you know younger woman and so
that's what they're getting out of it so
so it is like a transactional thing but
if it was more direct
okay if she was a prostitute
then then this would be sex work
and then according to the left and the
people that are complaining about it now
then everybody involved should be
applauded for their uh open-mindedness
for their Progressive open-mindedness
and that's probably the most absurd
contradiction of all is that is that
this is I think
would apply to almost every single
person that has tried to label Leonardo
DiCaprio a sex predator for dating
younger women
if the younger woman was a quote-unquote
sex worker was a prostitute and he was
directly paying her for her time and her
company then they would all be fine with
it
it's only because she's not a prostitute
that they refuse to applaud
you just you can't get more backwards
than that
that this that this uh relationship
between the two of them would only be
acceptable in their eyes if it was
prostitution and because it's not it's
not acceptable
my God these people are just you you
really you cannot get more morally
backwards than that
um
Joseph says Matt amongst all this
satanic evil I wanted to let you know
that your show inspired me to quit porn
an addiction I had since nine nine years
old my God find God and reconnect with
an old girlfriend whom I plan on
marrying soon thank you for what you do
well I love to hear that Joseph and
congratulations to you for getting your
life together
um
and then let's see finally
okay J star says I thought Matt was
going to cancel Maj Torre again I was
really really looking forward to it well
if you're looking forward to it then uh
I have good news coming up
as the Sweet Daddy of the sweet baby
gang one of my duties is to clothe you
give you proper gang paraphernalia to
represent the game gang uh just just
like the new notorious SBG t-shirt in my
swag Shack over at dailywire.com shop
it's a great new addition to the Sweet
Baby album T line which is all the fun
of Pop Culture with none of the Satan
worship so to reiterate what I said
yesterday in spite of my god-given
lyrical and rhythmic abilities
um I make no promises about spitting
bars for the gang uh this is a subject
that never even had to be broached at
all because it keeps being put into the
copy at this point you're better off
using an AI program to rap for me which
I guess like probably you could just do
that have fun with whatever Pandora's
Box that statement just Unleashed and
head over to dailywire.com shop to get
your notorious SBG t-shirt today also
guys your lady loves you and means well
but without the proper nudge she just
might not get you uh the right
Valentine's Day gift she might get you
something like a silly stuffed bear or a
pair of boxers with her face on it and
then you'll have to pretend it's what
you always wanted how about you get
something you actually want like a
Jeremy's razors Valentine's gift bundle
now just 30 off she'll love the price
you'll love that it's uh not pink or
covered in cartoon Hearts it's uh the
sappiest of holidays of course but you
can keep your masculinity intact with
the new five blade sharpest truth
Precision five razor so your uh what I
guess you're buying this for yourself
for Valentine's Day or you're telling
her to buy it for you I don't know
growing your whiskers instead of Shaving
them like a true man should that's just
the start of dropping hints that you
want a luxurious Jeremy's beard kit just
make sure you do it fast so she orders
today to arrive in time for a
Valentine's Day send her to Jeremy's
racers.com to shop the 30 off Jeremy's
Razor's Valentine's bundle you'll both
be glad you did it also
tonight
it's finally here we're not talking
about the Uncle Joe's State of the Union
which will no doubt be filled with
Mumble mouth lies about how inflation is
actually good for us and
self-congratulatory victory laps for
sending us closer to World War III we're
talking about the insightful and
hilarious commentary from your favorite
daily wire plus host before and after
the address tonight at 8 15 PM Eastern
join me Ben Shapiro Michael Knowles
Andrew Clay mckennissones and Jeremy
boring for a one-of-a-kind commentary
experience will give you a fresh and
entertaining perspective on the state of
the union and you can watch the whole
thing on daily wire plus so tune in for
backstage tonight at uh 8 15 PM Eastern
at dailywireplus.com now finally let's
get to our daily cancellation
foreign
we have a repeat customer on our daily
daily cancellation as we must cancel
alleged right-wing commentator Maj Torre
you may remember Maj from his previous
appearance in this segment five or six
months ago he had become incensed when I
made the point that slavery is not an
exclusively white sin and that in fact
all Races practice slavery and were
victims of slavery Maj did not want this
truth to be acknowledged and so he
launched into a multi-day temper tantrum
attacking me on various platforms and
accusing me of racism I'm guessing his
feelings will be hurt once again after
the opening monologue today ever since
then
Maja has continued to look for any
opportunity to whine about me uh calling
me a clown and a bigot and other insults
always in response to points that I've
made that he then wildly and
intentionally misconstrues just last
week for example Maj was posting
Instagram videos and doing interviews on
other podcasts and tweeting up a storm
furiously attacking me for suggesting
that we should be tougher on crime in
this country he was very offended by
that and he said that my advocacy for
Law and Order makes me a neocon which
once again demonstrates maja's
unfortunate habit of using words without
knowing what they mean and just a quick
hint here I'm an anti-interventionist
who wants to suspend all foreign aid to
all countries so that alone precludes me
from ever being labeled a neocon you
might as well call me a vegan while
you're at it if you're just going to
throw labels at me that are literally
the opposite of who I am
um
I've generally ignored most of maja's
Crybaby fits in fact I've never
initiated any interaction with this guy
in my life I've never intentionally
tried to talk to him prior to the whole
slavery kerfuffle I vaguely knew of him
as sort of a right of Center Center
pundit and gun rights activist and I
would have considered him in many
respects an ideological Ally
but sadly homage would prefer to use my
name for clout and to take pot shots at
me as a means of building up his own
platform and increasing his own name
recognition as he sees it there's no
point in working with someone when you
can get more clicks and retweets by
tearing them down constantly and this is
a I have to tell you a depressingly
common occurrence in the right-wing
media sphere in particular
uh and it's one of the many reasons why
conservatives so often lose
all that to say
by acknowledging him I will be giving
him the attention he so desperately
seeks from me and uh I that's a that's a
a downside of this I generally try not
to feed the trolls yet I can't help but
make an exception in this case for
reasons that may soon become clear so
late last week a video went viral of a
vicious assault on a school bus in
Florida there was a large teenage boy
along with a couple other seemingly
smaller and younger boys
and they can be seen viciously beating a
nine-year-old girl as she sits on the
bus and if you haven't seen the footage
yet it's very upsetting fair warning but
here it is
[Applause]
[Music]
um and they could have killed her I mean
you beat someone over the head
repeatedly uh and you that's that's the
way to kill someone they didn't thank
God but they couldn't and they wouldn't
have cared if they did by the way
now the attacker in the video has been
arrested and will face charges though
there's no reason to think that he'll
ultimately end up with anything more
than a slap on the wrist because that's
usually the way these things go but the
fact remains
that the teenage boy beat the hell out
of a nine-year-old girl a third his size
it is a vicious brutal animalistic
behavior and should be condemned as such
which is why I tweeted on Friday that
these are quote children raised to be
animals
because that's what they are our friend
majore he didn't like that very much in
fact uh big surprise here he once again
decided that I was being racist Maj
responded so you know how these children
were raised you know their parents no
way that children do dumbass stuff on
their own even if raised right we
definitely know their race to be animals
must be from the same racial jungle
Biden talked about shaking my head
you're a clown
Maj then felt the need to record a video
where he reiterates some of these same
accusations and uh here it is
said it before we'll say it again Matt
Walsh is a clown in response to that
video that uh the children on the school
bus beating up on a nine-year-old girl
that hit them first Overkill dumb kids
should be punished for Overkill the kid
did hit them first however it's overduff
all right children being dumbass
children but Matt Walsh's response in
the quote tweet is children raised to be
animals as if he knows the parents as if
he knows how they were raised and their
the thread is indicative of the same
bigoted mindset that we're talking about
this is not a conversation about a
balanced approach to holding children
accountable for doing dumb things this
is a fake ass dog whistle to in essence
call black children raised to be animals
but you don't even know their parents
said it before said it again guys clown
I guess I guess those are the animals
right that come from the same racial
jungle that Biden said he didn't want
his children to be a part of
absolute clown
now the funny thing here is that Maj
would later go on to tweet that the
people criticizing him for the comments
you just heard there from him are
Karen's who have a victim mentality and
are crying racism
yes that's right we're crying racism
even though that's what he just did you
heard it but this is about the level of
cognitive dissonance you can expect from
the same guy who recently said that it's
reductive to use the phrase all lives
matter because you're stealing it from
BLM even as he has an entire line of
merchandise with the phrase black guns
matter so he can take the phrase for the
purpose of monetizing it but we can't
take it for the purpose of emphasizing
the value and worth of all human lives
that's maj3 for you but that's neither
here nor there I suppose as to the
present controversy there are a few
points I need to make first
maj
you say that I'm a clown
okay but if I'm a clown
what does that make the grown man
hanging out in my comment section it's
either plenty of people on the internet
people like say you for example who I
think have nothing interesting or
especially intelligent to offer who I
think are absolute idiots
but the good thing is that I'm not
forced to see or interact with our
content nor am I compelled to reply to
everything they say
so I guess my point is that if you
really don't respect my point of view if
I'm just a clown as far as you're
concerned then and I'm trying to put
this as nicely as I can
piss off dude go live your life I
release you from any obligation to be my
reply guy in fact you never had any such
obligation so that's the good news
second I never said anything about the
races of the children involved it may
shock you to learn this but I am opposed
to teenage boys of any race brutalizing
nine-year-old girls of any race
you know you are the one who has once
again found a way to racialize something
while accusing everyone else of
racializing it because you're also a
coward who can't stand on your own words
and since you clearly do see this
through a racial lens and you've made it
a racial issue I must wonder whether you
would be so desperate to minimize the
actions of the assailants if they were
white boys beating up a black girl
after all I mean you must have some kind
of motivation that would drive you to
utterly humiliate yourself by using the
she started it excuse
now it's not at all clear from the video
who actually did hit first first and
even if you you uh did see a first hit
in the video
that wouldn't tell you what happened
right before the video started you see
videos almost always begin after the
action starts otherwise there'd be no
reason for anyone to be filming in the
first place okay something happens
someone pulls out their phone starts
filming so the first thing you see in
the video is not the first thing that
happened maj
but that's all completely and totally
irrelevant
there is no circumstance that would ever
even begin to justifies or minimize the
brutal physical assault of a
nine-year-old girl
who is cowering with her hands over her
head while being pummeled in the skull
okay
there are plenty of cases where the
details about who started it really
matter
a fight between two teenage boys for
instance I think in that case it matters
who started it
but when a little girl in third grade is
being pummeled over the head by a
teenage boy the question of who started
it could not be less relevant and it's
only brought up by someone looking to
minimize the guilt of the assailant
of course you do issue a half-hearted
denunciation of the assault by saying
that the boys were being dumb and simply
overdid it when they repeatedly bashed a
nine-year-old girl over the head no Maj
that's not typical dumb kid behavior and
it's not overdoing it to overdo
something implies that there's a certain
level of doing it that would be
appropriate
but when the it's in question is the
physical assault of a nine-year-old girl
there's no level that could ever be
defensible obviously
obvious to me anyway
just like we don't condemn an arsonist
who burns down a building by saying well
he's overdoing it
because that would obviously imply that
he's not necessarily wrong for setting
fire to the building but that the fire
shouldn't have been as big
in fact overdoing it is exactly the sort
of phrase you use when you don't want to
fully condemn a certain action which
again raises the question of why you
wouldn't want to fully condemn these
Savage physical assault of a small child
yes I said Savage
you can cry about that too
hopefully you know this is also a
question that you may ask yourself while
looking in the mirror and wondering
about the sort of man you've become
third you're right that I don't know
these boys parents I don't know them
from the looks of it they probably don't
know their parents either certainly not
their fathers and I can assume that
because boys with good and attentive
fathers they don't beat the hell out of
little girls
now it's true that we as parents we
can't directly control everything our
kids do actually in a literal and
Technical sense we can't directly
control almost anything they do okay
because they aren't remote control cars
or puppets on strings and if that's what
we mean by control like actually
physically control their movements like
their drones or robots that's not how it
works with human beings they have free
will and they act on their own volition
as parents it's maybe more precise to
say that we influence our children for
better or worse
you may not be in a position to actively
control your kid when he's on the school
bus and you aren't even physically
present but your influence is present
even when you aren't
and if your teenage child is viciously
assaulting a third grader that certainly
speaks and speaks very poorly to your
parental influence
my guess which is based not on racist
dog whistles as you claim but rather on
a simple understanding of human nature
is that the boys in the video come from
homes filled with violence and emotional
and psychological chaos
children need moral formation this is
the most important kind of influence we
can give them and refusing to take
charge of that process of moral
formation is a form of moral formation
itself which is really moral deformation
that there are many morally deformed
kids running around these days thanks to
their morally deformed parents
now if I'm wrong and it turns out that
the teenage boy was who was brutally
assaulting a nine-year-old girl actually
comes from a loving and intact
two-parent household where they eat
dinners together and they go to church
and they have family board game nights
and so on then I will admit that the boy
is an exception to the rule still
wouldn't change the rule the rule which
says that children raised to be decent
human beings will generally become
decent human beings and those raised to
be animals will generally become animals
but I don't think this is an exception
I really doubt that
The Only Exception today is that uh I've
broken my usual habit of ignoring you
and your desperate cries for my
attention
a habit that I plan to resume once again
starting right now
this is all
just a way of saying that homage Torre
is today once again canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]